اهلا بكم الى موجز الانباء من الجزيره
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا ارساله 31
دبابه من طرازي ابرامز الى اوكرانيا مؤكده
انه سيتم في الوقت القريب تدريب عليها
وقال بعيدن الروس فشلوا في التفريق بين
واشنطن وحلفيها واكد ان كل من بريطانيا
وفرنسا والمانيا ستقدم دبابات قتاليه
لاوكرانيا
واكد الناطق باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الجنرال بات رايدر في حوالين خاصه مع
الجزيره ان الولايات المتحده ستقدم
لاوكرانيا طراز الاحدث من دبابات ابرامز
وان الخطوه ستمنح القوات الاوكرانيه تفوقا
سريعا في المعارك وكانت الحكومه الالمانيه
اكدت رسميا انها وافقت على ارسال دبابات
الى اوكرانيا واقل المستشار الالماني انك
قرار الانتظار الذي تم اتخاذه للتنسيق
والتعاون الدولي بشان تسليم المعدات
الاوكرانيا كان صحيحا
في المقابل علينا الجيش الروسي وعن اجراء
تدريبات في الجزء الغربي من المحيط
الاطلسي على استخدام الصواريخ التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت بواسطه محاكاه
الكمبيوتر في حضون ذلك قالت سفاره روسيا
في المانيا ان قررت تزويد كيف بدبابات لي
بارد خطير للغايه وينقل الصراع الى مستوى
جريده
استدعى النائب العام اللبنانيه المحققا
العدليه في انفجار مرفا بيروت للمثول
امامه اليوم الخميس واصدر امرا بمنعه من
السفر كما قرر النائب العام اطلاقا صلاح
جميع الموقوفين في قضيه انفجار المرفق
وعددهم 17 اما البيطار فقد علينا رفضه هو
التنحيه عن الملف ووصف اخلاقي سبيل
الموقوفين بانه انقلاب على القانون وقد
تحضر رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب
ميقاتي من انقسامات القضاء تنظر بتداعيات
خطيره من جهتها حتى الخارجيه الامريكيه
السلطات اللبنانيه على استكمال تحقيق سريع
وشفاف في الانفجار بيروت
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي باحات
المسجد الاقصى المبارك ومسجد قبه الصخره
وكان وزير الامن القومي اي ثمار بنجبير قد
قال انه سيواصل اقتحامته للمسجد الاقصى
وذلك رغم التعهدي رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو امس الاول خلال لقائه مع العهد
الاردني بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم في
الاقصى
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
الفلسطيني برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي شرقيه
قلقيليه بالضفه افادت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بان الشابه حاول طعنه مستوطن
كان يقف عند محطه الحفلات عند مدخل
مستوطنه
كادوميلها هذا وافدت مصادره فلسطينيه
باستشهاد فتى في مخيم شعفاطات شرقيه القدس
متاثرا برصاصه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اختراق اقتحام المخيم باعداد كبيره صباح
امس
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه زي ما كنتم قام
توقعاتكم بكل خير